casi 24 horas después las fuerzas
somalíes pusieron fin al asedio del
hotel hyatt un lugar popular entre los
legisladores y otros funcionarios del
gobierno somalí el brutal atentado
cometido por el grupo extremista
islámico al shabab comenzó en la noche
del viernes con explosiones en el
exterior del hotel
posteriormente los hombres armados
entraron en el edificio e intercambiaron
disparos con las fuerzas de seguridad
dejando varios muertos y heridos
todos corrían hacia el lugar donde
creían que estarían a salvo pero tele
empezó a llenarse de humo y llamas y en
seguida había uno de los cuatro espaldas
del hotel sangrando y a otro hombre
debido
este es el mayor ataque en mogadicio
desde la posición del nuevo presidente
de somalia hassan sheikh mohamud hace
tres meses y se produce en la misma
semana en que eeuu anunció la muerte de
13 combatientes de al shabab en una
ofensiva aérea en efecto la comunidad
internacional condenó el ataque la onu
en somalia condena enérgicamente el
atentado de al shabab contra el hotel
hyatt en mogadicio y transmite sus
condolencias a las familias de las
víctimas desea una pronta recuperación a
los heridos y expresa su solidaridad con
todos los somalíes en su lucha contra el
terrorismo al shabab sigue siendo el
grupo extremista islámico más letal de
áfrica lleva 15 años luchando para
derrocar al gobierno somalí quiere
establecer su propio gobierno basado en
una interpretación estricta de la ley
islámica